hey everyone today we've got a super
exciting video for you in which i will
be taking you through the rpg game from
free code camp that teaches you how to
code with me is the game creator
lin so without further ado lynn is there
anything you want to say before starting
uh sure i'm lilly i'm a recent graduate
from the university of chicago
from my cs degree
and i'm now a software engineering here
at salesforce in san francisco and in my
free time as you might see on the screen
the
thing i do the most is game development
all right um let me tell you something
about the game
um the idea first started in april when
quincy had this idea brewing in his mind
he reached out to me by late july
when i was planning my move here to san
francisco
and
i jumped on this opportunity i started
my four month long development
the process took i think four months
times four weeks per month times ten
plus hour per month
and that should take us to 160 hours
plus
and that's excluding the graphics
because the graphic the graphics were
done by an artist we found and quincy
himself did the music so the coding the
writing
took me 160 hours plus
that's incredible i mean i can't wait to
stop playing this game that is
a lot of time and education i know that
quincy spent over 25 hours on the music
so everyone watching if you want to
check that out please do pay attention
to the music throughout this game
if you want to make the music louder by
the way you can adjust the volume here
so this is the music volume which is
actually different to the sound volume
of the game itself
so as you can see here we are just
changing the sound volume which is a
nice tip and lin you were saying this
was also accessible to everyone is that
correct
yep
so the moving text that's an
accessibility feature i believe yeah
because sometimes for the effects you
will have bouncy wavy tags over the
screen and if you're not used to that
kind of a graphics display you can turn
it off
amazing
well i'm excited i think everyone here
just wants to get to play the game so
let's get to it
first off i'm gonna start by creating a
new game like i said i've never played
this before so i'm going on a journey
with you okay
so here we are on the screen we are
going to learn how to code and this is
essentially mimicking that right so here
we are
uh i guess i'm being interviewed for a
job here where they've looked at my
resume and they're going to give me an
online assessment so
let's do it i guess i have another
options and we're going to look at the
first question so here we are on the
first
question and what we how do you prove
that oh okay
ah
was that the question because i
reading it okay second question
please continue your question yeah i had
i didn't realize okay well obviously
let's try for the second question second
question in python what is a generator
what banana nuts i don't know i'm
guessing okay well that's that i mean
that's the real interview
you have a time limit
i am bombing these questions sad
question okay i'm gonna concentrate on
this one how do you why are they all
banana nuts and how do you explain how
the internet works for five year old
what
oh my god
i'm guessing this is on purpose right
i'm not
vomiting really hard we're not taking
you straight to the bad ending
not yet
thanks for taking the time to complete
our coding interview well that went bad
uh i'm really hoping that's on purpose
and part of the coding journey before
you go please take some time to fill in
your basic information
okay cool
wow if that's what the game is going to
be like i'm just going to give up now
lynn because
phew looks like i survived the technical
questions barely i would not say that
was the case
i'm just going to fill in my details i'm
assuming
how did you hear about us
okay i'm going to go for a referral
because i'm going to put you
then
let's do that
oh that's cool i was referred by a vip
member i
that's pretty awesome lynn i guess
you're a vip team member
we'll make sure that our vip team member
didn't know so i like that feature
you're obviously
oh that's an achievement unlocked woohoo
you've got an easter egg
amazing
so there's 54 achievements to be
unlocked i just got the first one
and i'm guessing i can tweet about it
right right
so
if i just click on this
i just got refurbed by a vip
member
that's pretty cool
i'm not going to share it now as this
game is not live so i don't want people
or should i tweet it what do you think
lin yeah keep it a secret for now okay
i'm gonna keep this secret okay so
obviously you guys can tweet about your
achievements though um i'm just gonna
continue playing
what i do okay
i'm gonna click yes
way to go so now i'm notified about
events and opportunities
i like how realistic this is in terms of
you know the process for when you are
applying for jobs and stuff okay so here
we go ania sai
that was exhausting there's no doubt
that i bombed those questions i did i
did not do very well geez coding
interviews are hard they are hard
they are hard i completely agree what
what made me think i could get a
software job in the first place
okay so now i think we're going back in
time well it all started some time ago
about three months ago to be exact
let's learn to coach
okay so
we've gone back in time
august 1st i believe
and i'm in high school or
okay that's what chicago module is all
about yep the basics are phenomenal okay
i need to reread my notes to make sure i
have everything for the day
so this is okay oh i see i'm
tutoring high school kids at the moment
i've graduated from college but getting
a full-time job is very difficult
i've heard back from none of the jobs
that i have just applied for
and even though i like tutoring kids uh
you need a filter i need a full-time job
that is more fulfilling and of course
pays more money pays those bills
and the kid asks me hey anya oh hey
sorry i just spaced out a bit
daydreaming about new jobs
do you have any more questions before we
wrap up
nope i think my project report is good
to go thanks
good i'll see you next week oh sorry can
we do the week after next i just heard
about a new class that teaches you how
to code and build robots and i need to
check that and i need to check that out
next week sure no problem see you there
yeah high school students are beating
you at learning to code already oh no
i was thinking like am i going to join
this class
but i'm at home now my mom says hey
sweetie welcome back
welcome pumpkin how was your day
my mom is a high school teacher which is
why she could find me this tutoring gig
and my dad is a mechanical engineer but
i never got too into engineering not to
brag but they are the nicest parents i
know oh i like that that's really sweet
i had an okay day i'm tutoring the smart
kid wants to take up coding classes i
can't believe that came from a high
school student
yeah so i'm obviously feeling like i
want to do some coding at the moment
and my mom is telling me that
high school students are
enrolling as coding classes as it's
trendy that's i didn't know
i mean i reckon that's pretty true i
didn't do coding in high school but i
guess
maybe now it's a different time
yeah i remember our neighbor the guy who
moved away last month i had his kid in
majoring in computer science like
college the kid is only a junior but is
already intending for big companies
during summer break wow that's pretty
cool that is pretty cool
dinner's ready
thanks mom you're the best
that was cute i like this oh dumplings
i'm i'm enjoying the journey that i've
been taking on
so here's the best part about my day
so we're having conversation and i'm up
for anything
and here's my room
a notification from my phone must be
something on social media
what do we do i'm gonna
obviously i'm gonna check my phone i'm
not gonna ignore it let's go for that
one
looks like someone from my junior high
school i don't even remember who they
are
what did they post to get this crazy
number of likes
oh
[Laughter]
yes that is cool how did you make this
go so bouncy is that a python thing or
was that a
how did you how did you do that
um it's a python and rent there are
those special text tags that you can use
to make animated effects
oh fun okay
i haven't um checked out rempe before
but i love it it's looking cool
and i love swag who doesn't love swag
should i leave a like or comment on that
post
of course we're gonna leave a like
should we leave a like or should we
comment what should we do
i'm gonna leave a like
liked wow they've got 1k likes already
guess i'm one of them now
looks like you just made your first
in-game choice that's awesome so how do
you make the choices lynn is uh do you
want to share some code as in how you
wrote that in
uh rempe
because that's the first bit of i guess
choice that we have to do or the second
or so
yeah sure let me just get my script
ready
would you mind on sharing so that i can
take over the share yeah
all right do you see my screen yes
alright so we have our learn to code rpg
here this is the rempey launcher
and i'm just gonna open up the script
and go back to the place where we are
asked to leave a like
so here's how it
looks in code the player is smiling we
change the player's sprite to the smiley
sprite should i leave a like or comment
you leave a like there's a different
dialogue if you post a comment there's a
different dialogue if you do something
there's a different dialogue and you can
see the choices are nested because you
chose to check the phone you got taken
to this part of the
conversation if you did nothing instead
you just have a relaxing evening
amazing and this choice that we make it
doesn't have any consequence or anything
further at the moment right it it just
it just affects what text will be
returned back to you yeah you cut my
developer comment there but yeah
there are more choices down the line
that will actually
do something to the plot of the story
okay great that's really exciting
thanks for sharing that we'll be cutting
into code as we continue playing the
game as well so just be aware of
that i'm going to go ahead and share
my screen now
okay so back to the game let's continue
the game i'm going to click to continue
you will encounter many choices in this
game later on there are no right or
wrong choices only consequences
so it might be a good idea to save your
progress okay that's a good idea let's
go ahead and save our progress forward
thank you for the reminder
okay so let's go with this empty slot
wonderful
and return back
i like the save progress
function with the empty slots that's
really cool
yeah that's actually built into a rim
pie so i didn't have to do much heavy
lifting amazing
would you like to get future reminders
on your set yes let's keep reminders on
and click yes
oops
cool and sit and scan your friendly say
reminder now let's write to our story
oops did i just doze off something about
coding interviews not the coding
interview again
it's crazy having a new day to learn
code and getting high paying jobs and
software
six months of self-placed learning and
then a six figure job talk about the end
of craziness
hmm but i can see the appeal in that
maybe i can learn to code as well
oh that's cute hello little mint
the the cat agrees with me so that's
good
that's a good sign
the mint is definitely one of the
reasons i decided to move back home all
right let's do this a bit of research
won't hurt where shall we start maybe i
should find some free online resources
like everyone else is doing well we know
a great free resource free code cam so
let's here's a video about the top 10
tech skills worth learning in 2021 let's
check that out
i'll keep track of my progress on my
phone
okay so let's click on the
phone
to check out our stats so here we are we
are googling some stats
so java and javascript are different
languages
wait which one is for web dev again
i was insanity
cs knowledge
so that is showing us
sanity decreases oh okay so that's our
sanity as a person
and there's our computer science
knowledge that's pretty cool
i remember one video saying that python
2 is outdated does that mean i don't
have to learn it
oh
maybe i shouldn't even bother landing
with python3
several majors decide that python 3 is
too old-fashioned before i even get a
chance to learn it
but what am i doing java doesn't sound
like a good idea either it's really old
people nowadays are so hyped about
kotlin
why is my sanity decreasing if i click
show
to do am i
it's actually not decreasing it's just
you're advancing the dialogues
oh i see okay
javascript or typescript are they like
cousins or something
maybe i could oh
maybe i can find a job posting i like
and start learning their required skills
but what is front end back end or full
stack what are the differences
what are devops and site reliability
engineering and why is this compute why
is this company using that pet coding
language that nobody else
uses
ah this is so frustrating
and you get the notification that your
cs knowledge is set to zero oh i see
okay so at the moment we've got a base
of zero and we're going to increase this
computer science knowledge i'm guessing
along the way yeah and keeping your
sanity at an acceptable level oh nice
okay
learn to code her i guess it's not that
easy there might be people who are cut
out to do this but definitely not me i
guess i better call it a day and go to
bed
oh i definitely have that have you ever
not been able to sleep because you just
got code on your mind because that
happens to me so much
i dream about code and then when i wake
up i can start writing code and
debugging
i'm definitely like laid away
because i'm just so frustrated thinking
about something or just even like
planning my next day and like i'm just
like okay so tomorrow i have to do this
and maybe i can try this but yeah like
there's many nights where i have um not
been able to sleep because of that
i still need to pay the bills even if my
parents are nice enough not to ask for
rent let's check out the coffee shop
next door tomorrow and see if they're
hiring
[Music]
a learning buddies make it better i like
it how it's broken up into chapters as
well
do i mirror a personal objection call
from the neighborhood coffee
oh
annika geez when was the last time you
called me when are we moving out off to
graduation
best friend
that's a college best friend right there
oh nice okay
well yes annika my best friend from
college is here to join the game
anyways it's really nice to hear from
you again
same how have you been i've been okay
just new ground blues you things are
going pretty well for me i just got a
job offer and like it's not just any job
it's a web development job what has this
girl got a web development job and we we
don't yet
can you believe it i get paid really
well to build cool websites it's almost
like getting paid for being creative and
doing up
wow congrats
thanks
hey annika how hard was it for you to
learn to develop websites i also tried
to learn the code for a while but it got
too hard and i quit
i'm sorry to hear that but you should
give coding another try that's true
that's true it is quite hard um at the
beginning it's definitely
harder than people say sometimes i think
it's easy like easy peasy it wasn't easy
it wasn't like easy peasy for me either
like neither of us major in computer
science the computer science kids have a
way easier time getting a job you did
take some cs electives in school didn't
you yeah but those skills are pretty
rusty and honestly what you learn is
that is true what you learn at school
just becomes becomes outdated as well i
feel right pretty quick
yeah and i feel at school you know you
learn like html and css and it pretty
much stops it there or at least it did
for me anyway
yeah
i've been self-studying all these months
using some awesome free resources i even
got a ped adoption website as a side
project and that's when i applied okay
that's pretty cool
and there was this bug that i had no
idea how to fix until
dot dot dot suspense
oh i've been talking for a long time
no worries it does that you're doing
something you enjoy that must be really
cool i wish i could be like you well
anyway you can
you curly can i give i did i give you
the link to the awesome resource that
i've been using it's called free code
cam
way you hover over it it's something
that you can actually check out
amazing
okay cool so it takes you to the um
i guess just to the home page of free
code camp with some
alumni
that's a in-game title drop
oh yeah i like is that what they're
officially called engaged in game title
drops could be i just came up with it
right i
thanks i will let's add it to my to-do
list
great okay so we actually already did
this that's quite cool i like how it's
incorporated into the gameplay
show to do is how do i do i have to
click it again for it to register um no
this will be checked off sometime later
in the game oh i think
what's your plan for the day
i need to check out the neighboring
coffee shop oh yeah because we're
getting a job let's catch up some time
and get coffee sure chat later
and let's click save i'm going to keep
saving do anything do return and it will
take
it will take you to the page
if i return uh yeah just click to
continue and it will take you to the
page oh i see
okay cool
yes that's good to know as well
all right
you didn't click on the numpty slot to
save so it's probably not saved yet but
that shouldn't be too much of a problem
okay well the next time i guess we can
do that properly you can you can always
save it whenever you like just hit
escape yeah this or escape
and save it whenever
and then all right because that's what
we saved last time so if i click here
if you click on the first one it will
overwrite the save
but you have an even the number of saves
available so
no worries that's good to know so
okay so at the moment we're at the
coffee shop
it needs a part-time barista
this reminds me so much of college i
used to work part-time as a barista at
the school library cafe as well it's
always nice to see my peers socializing
and doing cough work at the cafe i love
to work at cafes
an additional perk is that i get
first-hand knowledge of interesting
things that happen on campus
let's have a look
i love that the multi-million
dollar startup not possible given not
impossible given that the tech scene is
booming in our quiet little town or at
least they might be talking about
something interesting happening in the
tech industry
hey did you hear that our school is
getting a computer lab wow really
okay
and the boy's asking her what happens at
the computer lab and the girl is saying
that we can build our own video games i
love building um games
and i heard that we'll have a dedicated
teacher to lead a club or even host
hackathons and stuff
that is pretty cool i um i wish i did
computer science sometimes at university
and got to take part in hackathons
and loads of stuff like that
you know like running a map i love this
description of a hackathon like running
a marathon but you can hack away at some
project instead of running around
that's actually needed you need the
stamina and the snacks to survive a
hackathon just like a marathon have you
done already yeah
and water and sleep i've done one or two
or have you what at university or a
place you're studying or just for fun
yeah the university of chicago
just started college once oh cool
was it like a two-day one or a one-day
one oh i'm a two-day one oh wow that was
a stretch yeah
do you know about this thing called a
visual novel game tell me about it okay
here it goes
i love that i wasn't intentionally
eavesdropping on high school kids but
how can i a hackathon idea they
mentioned is new i think i can use this
piece of information to my advantage
let's make it to let's add it let's make
it a to-do list item to ask annika if
she knows about events like this this is
some good advice actually for people who
are you know sort of going coding i
think being in the know about events
such as hackathons is definitely
something you should do as lynn
mentioned
oh wow we just achieved another um we
unlocked another achievement
that's pretty awesome we have we have a
long way to go this is great this is a
fun game and it's uh we're gonna have a
lot of knowledge by the end of it i can
already tell
and the barista is your undercover
identity for collecting buzzwords keep
that in mind
[Music]
okay cool
barista so we're going to remember the
word barista as an undercover identity
ew it's been a long day at work
let's check out the awesome resource
that annika was talking about what was
it called again i mean i think i've got
an unfair advantage here
because i definitely know which one it
is
what happens if we click another one
like freebie goodies go for it
that doesn't sound like the right name i
never you must be playing tricks on me
okay well we know it's recommended let's
just go with that
wow the curriculum is super
comprehensive they also offer
certifications that i can showcase on my
resume beat
that is pretty neat what should i start
with
okay
surely let's start at the beginning
because i think that's probably the best
thing to do
yeah okay responsive web design
what even is web design i'm not a design
person will i be able to follow along
maybe look looks okay so we're not meant
to choose
that one
i mean
we can look at some algorithms
oh wait maybe it's java what algorithms
data structures that sounds like math
which is not my favorite subject what
other curriculum options do i have
um i feel like it's trying to make me
pick something
[Music]
shall we just wait for annika's advice
or should we pick another let's just do
that
let's ask annika for advice tomorrow
cool so that's added to my to-do list
nice
yeah
the cat comes back and mint thinks it's
a great idea to ask anika so that's what
we're going with we're sticking with
that one
and
let's
save yes we do want to save
if you get
annoyed by the same reminder just turn
it off
okay i think for now it's fine maybe
we'll switch it off for the next one
thanks for entertaining another friendly
reminder next day
it's a new day already what's on our
to-do list today
right let's give anna go call and ask
about the computer science curriculum
what's up so i've been checking out free
curriculum suggested and i think it's
correct it's solid the thing is i have
no idea what to learn
okay so annika is going to give us all
the advice
because we think it looks very
complicated and you know there's a lot
of work as she said with each
certification so it's good to know where
to start
and anika says that she did the web
design one okay good
okay great so this is what we're going
to start annika is telling us this one
she did and i think it will be a good
one for us to start with as well she
managed to pull through the curriculum
because she had some experience from
college plus she has a real gift for
design
i'm not like that apparently there's no
way i can do this i say but i think i
can
so annika agrees with me she's going to
encourage me which is a good idea
i think already it's a big step forward
now that you've checked out their
curriculum trust me i was just like you
when i first started i was clueless so
we shot a freak out comes online
community that's also a great idea
annika is very clever
and yeah they're giving us some great
advice
the phone is a great yeah the forum is a
great place to check out advice and to
know where to start
yes
thank you lynn
so they also recommended that we start
with some general introduction to
computer science or quizzes
uh
so let's check it out
oh yes okay so these are the
certifications
that we got sent to before
and all you have to do is really sign up
to see
the web development uh responsive design
questions that are on here okay
so if you haven't already please sign up
it is free and then you will get taken
to
some responsive questions i mean i
should already be logged into this so
there we go so here is the responsive
web design certification and you just go
through
each of these questions
and try complete them okay
so that's all you have to do just go
through each one of them there's 28
uh little i guess
collapsible courses that you can get
through and then you go into css and so
on and so on so just make sure to do
those in order and then you will finish
the responsive web design
of course
great
yes so they are really bite-sized they
are quite fun and essentially you just
go through them and try pass each
question
annie is saying that she's not sure
if she can complete them and what
happens if we run into something we
can't understand
well
again we have the community right loan
so the community is also on hand to help
you
there's a channel especially for this so
if you ever get stuck just go on and
someone from freco camp or the free
procurement community will be able to
help you with your question
uh and annika's also saying that she's
going to be our accountability buddy
great that's good thanks adam
she really is a best friend
anya and annika forever
right okay annika's heading up work best
of luck
okay so that's one more item that we can
check off our to-do list
great
time to go to my barista shift
okay i'm going to turn them off now
i'm gonna say my progress again
so now i've just turned off the save
reminders just for everyone following
along
yeah you can go to settings and turn it
on or off at any time
okay so that's also
something you can do
yeah the others there's a saving save
reminder
text right there okay so i'll turn it
off by making sure that it is
disabled
and let's carry on
okay so we're back at the cafe back at
our work shift but today there's not
many people
okay
so i guess we're making ourselves a
coffee i mean what developer doesn't
like coffee i personally love decaf
coffee
and wow that was that's great because
our shift is over so
we're gonna do some studying we've
finished our shifts and now let's get to
studying something at home
so let's head over to develop a quiz and
try out some questions um actually you
might want to just go back to the game
oh
and there will be in-game quizzes
okay looks like they even divide the
questions the subcategories like html
css and javascript and wonderful i like
how there's a tracker that's really
helpful and i think will really help us
sort of understand how far along we are
with our learning
so i think that's a really good feature
how did you make that feature by the way
should we go into code for that i think
that might be a good idea
yeah sounds great
let's go to the file where i um
that should be player stats dot rpy so
the dot rpy file tells vampire that's a
rand pi file
ramp is based on python so all the code
we are seeing here are like python code
nice so we have a
stats map where you see the sanity and
cs knowledge there's also something
called all skills that i define
somewhere else in variables
rpy
um
before i show you the
skills
i'm just gonna quickly show you the
layout
so we have sanity here i'm using the
grid to display the thing if you
remember there's a sanity there's a cs
knowledge and for each subcategory
of knowledge
we also make that
part of the
screen so you can see we always have a
stats name and a bar value
and yeah that's pretty much it
variables variables is where we keep our
in-game secrets
great so whenever we complete a section
we're just adding
a value to one of the variables right
one of the skills
right it's
amazing i mean that's
really good to see in code i really
appreciate you showing us that all right
cool
so let's carry on and let's
give it a go should i study for a
specific category or mix and match
categories i think specific
let's just go specific for now and start
with the very first one i think or
should we do html lynn which one do you
want to do
up to you
maybe let's do each now
okay html it is
so first off
of course it's nice to know what html
actually stands for as well let's go for
it
last question yeah sorry we have a total
of over 600 questions in our question
back wow okay that is i mean i'm so
impressed with how much and bear in mind
everyone we're just on achievement
number two so there is a lot to this
game by the end like our our knowledge
of computer science and web development
is going to be
crazy high especially if you've never
done development before
so what is the title target html
the title tag when subtitles conditional
headings display the paragraph defines
the title for html document so you're
just going to be asked lots of questions
and of course if you get it right you
get a correct
you get a oh i got 10 points
[Music]
[Laughter]
nice and i guess if you don't get it
right then it might show you
my um you know [ __ ] let's try to get an
incorrect answer
so what's cool span i'm just gonna go
with something
okay so wrong it just sort of vibrates
and then
it gives you the correct answer
so that's quite useful as well because
sorry carry on we're gonna say something
there's a learn more button if you hover
over it
yeah
nice
if you want to go more in-depth into the
subject into the question you can always
check out it in the article
so this is incredible i can't even
imagine how much
work this had to be not only to create
the questions but then to you know find
an article or a piece of information on
pre-cocam to essentially link to
allow someone to read more and learn
more about the topic that's
amazing really yeah i had a lot i had a
few people on the team to help me out
to come up with questions and organize
them do you want to see a quick
yeah you want to quickly see it in code
and you will be amazed by the number of
questions
wow these are all the css questions it's
a long scroll so for each question
australia we got the true the false the
explanation the learn more url and
everything it's a long scroll
i like how it's a difficulty one as well
and bear in mind these quiz questions
for everything for all the
for all the quiz okay wow that's
incredible
i can see how this would have taken
a crazy amount of time i'm so so
impressed
here you got javascript ones
it's a it's a long scroll to the bottom
yeah we're already on 3800
so
i mean if you could only imagine how
many questions that will take up that is
crazy
i love it
all right awesome thanks
okay
so let's move on
correct code for linking css style sheet
to an html file so these are essentially
all the
this one
that's right isn't it it doesn't need an
end tag okay good
um so there we go so we've just
increased our score on html that would
have been 30 if the second one we didn't
get
incorrect on purpose to see the
incorrect
i guess gameplay
and
let's carry on
last question actually well attribute
shows you what attribute should you add
to input to create a checkbox checkbox
i'm glad that was an easy one to edward
okay
[Music]
but also it's good to see sort of um
i really like the learn more
functionality i thought that was really
good and it was great to see that in
there too
all done another achievement a lot
so our html achievement is now a lot
that is pretty cool it's safe to the
bonus menu so we can also tweet about it
of course i'm not going to tweet now
because this is not yet released uh at
the moment of recording it will be
released by the time that you watch this
so
yeah i will be obviously that makes
sense because yes it will be officially
launched what i'm saying the game will
be officially launched by the time you
watch this
yeah okay
would you like to go to the banner
screen
yes let's do it let's go to the bonus
screen how do i get that settings
and then
left hand side
achievements
oh nice
so that's the easter egg that we found i
love that there's so many does this mean
there was two that we've missed two
easter eggs that we missed
so if you really want and you complete
the game you can go through the game
again to try and find all the easter
eggs that could be a fun side like a
side
mission
in itself
great so there is a lot to unlock i mean
i think once we've got to the coding
part it's it's really it's really going
to take a lot of brain power so don't
feel you have to do everything in one go
if you're just learning this code it
could be worth you know taking a break
to do some additional learning while
you're doing this game there's nothing
that you know is forcing you to do this
uh
you know
just directly step by step by step
cool
so we are now tired after a long day of
work we have achieved and unlocked the
html achievement so now let's say
goodnight to mint and
go to the next day
i also like how the date is in the
corner
as a sort of other way to track your
progress i guess
so how do you calculate the date from
the back is this calculated based on
today's date does it go back in time
three months or is it just an arbitrary
date that you have
it's a hard coded one oh nice okay cool
because the recruiting process for
tech companies usually start around
october and november and that's when you
will learn something about coding and
are ready to tackle those coding
interviews
okay i get it that makes sense i like
that
let's go to the kitchen and all these
animations did you say you worked with
an artist to create them
uh those transitions are actually built
into vampire but
the character sprites you see on the
side and the arnica sprites these are
created by the artist and the background
images are just stock images and i
applied some watercolor filter to them
so they look like no way in game
backgrounds
i can't believe that that's such a good
idea i mean i can't believe that's an
image that you just transformed
a stock photo
yes
but the uh the drawings of the
characters are amazing so whoever the
artist is shout out shout out to them
for sure
and the toast is drawn by me because my
artist wanted to focus on creating
characters oh cute
i love it
how did you make the uh drawing
like what did you use
oh i i do digital art on the side so i
have like drawing apps on my
ipad and my apple pencil amazing
and i drew mint that's like the one
thing i'm proud of
[Laughter]
i love mint what a great side character
oh do you want to mix and match let's
mix and match
mixing and matching all cashews sounds
like fun let's bring in the potpourri
uh great first question what is the name
of the rule that will override css style
for an element i actually don't know
this
let's go with override i want to say
important but
this is a question i don't know so
blue blue i don't know let's go override
it was important wasn't it i knew it
that was intentional
always good with your god apparently
but also the
person who came up with the quiz
question did a really good job of
creating all those distractors
yeah
i mean yeah that was um
that was a great question
if you watch my youtube videos you'll
know my css knowledge isn't super great
i mainly focus on javascript and react
and stuff
um
so let's see how i do with this rgb it
stands for red green and blue so i know
that one
html is like an external javascript file
without a script correct
form
cool
so as you can see again we have now
completed more questions on html
that was html right wasn't it html
section oh you didn't mix and match but
because we have the most number of html
questions if we're drawing randomly from
the sample it will just show up more
often
great okay so yes we did a mix and match
one so that is quite good as obviously
then you don't really know what to
expect
and annika's back
okay so annika hey anya that's perfect i
just got back from work annika is going
to tell us that we're great and we're
awesome
oh she's learning to use the custom web
the framework that her company uses it's
pretty different okay that's interesting
and exciting so i like how we get to
talk to annika because she gives us some
insight into what it's like to work at
an actual
software development company which i
think is always interesting to hear
especially when you're you know just
starting out
she's had a lot of good things about
this framework that she's using mostly
from people that she ran into at the
local hackerspace
that is cool hackathons okay great this
is a great reminder because women to ask
anika about hackathons
and she's also mentioned hackerspace
hello to anya we're obviously
daydreaming about hacker
space
what topic we're gonna ask her about
well let's ask let's start off with
asking her about hackathons
[Music]
and
as lynn mentioned it is an event that
people come together and essentially
design and implement cool tech projects
lens was two days worth but you can get
24 hour hackathons you can get on remote
hackathons there's there's really like
they've taken the idea of a hackathon
and it's sort of evolved into anything
that anyone wants which i think is quite
cool
and yes it's also a great way to
to mingle with people who perhaps
are at a different level to you which is
always quite useful or a great way to
network with people who work at specific
companies so for example say you want to
work at a specific company and they're
throwing a hackathon and you would
potentially like to work there or just
learn what it's like to work about what
it's like to work there i would
definitely suggest going mm-hmm
and yes as annika says great they look
great on your resume
and
searching online is definitely a great
way to find them there's plenty of
resources out there
twitter is always a good one i think to
stay on top of news about hackathons or
just events in the
computer
science space
so
great thanks annika for that knowledge
and we can also now check it off our
list
and we can also learn about hacker space
so that wasn't obviously just a question
we can select all the answers
if we want and go through them
hacker space is something that i haven't
had i haven't heard of it perhaps it's a
geographical thing
as hacker space isn't for the cyber
criminal types of hackers it's a chill
space for people to gather work and
build cool projects
it's almost like a
shared co-working environment where you
just come together and build stuff oh
that's really cool
i might check it out as well
so is it a
in is it an in-person thing or an online
thing then
mostly in person like when i first moved
here to san francisco quincy was highly
suggesting something called noise bridge
i think but i haven't had a chance to go
there because i come of it yeah of
course yeah i don't know if we have any
of those in london there's definitely
hackathons
but not hacker spaces so if there is one
in london that i should hear about and
every and anyone out there knows of one
please let me know
great that's everything i need to know
thanks annika annika's like great i love
her
everyone is an annika in their lives
especially if you're starting to
learning to code you need a
body like this yeah for sure
thanks and we're done
i love the little insights into my life
at home with my mum and dad as well
and some chicken today i learned you
animated the chicken as well you drew
that yeah
great to have such supportive parents as
well so that's really nice
great
so another another day of learning is
now done and we're going to bed i wonder
if it's worth you know if you are
playing this game and you are lying to
good through the game i wonder if it's
worth you know calling it a day at the
same time as your character calls it a
day what do you think lynn is that the
way the game is intended
and
whatever whenever you need to recharge
take a take some time off but they're
also in-game way to recharge as you will
see soon
nice okay well
hopefully we'll get to one of those soon
remember you need to keep your sanity up
and oh yeah
both of your in-game sanity and in-life
sanity up
okay cool
if we check how do we check our current
sanity stats
stats
so our salary is at 75. i think that's
quite high for sanity
uh i think today what shall we do
okay well if we work that will bring
down our sanity if we study again
they'll take let's let's just relax
let's get our sciency way up
yeah let's hang out with mint for a day
let's listen to some music
as we said quincy made the music so
let's maybe pick a track that we want to
listen to
let's go with crystallize that inner
child
[Music]
yeah so if you are interested in seeing
the music that quincy made you can see
all the tracks here
and have a listen so take a chill
relax
get up that sanity before continuing to
play oh no way we got an achievement
is that because we listen to the game
yes chill beats to ko nice
so that is a achievement that you can
unlock as well just by listening to some
of the amazing music that is on the game
and we've increased our sanity by 17 so
that is good what happens if our sanity
gets to lolin are we not able to
continue playing
yeah you might be all right i'm gonna
keep this a secret you might be forced
into doing some activities that will
eventually
raise your sanity or you might encounter
some special easter eggs
fun
[Music]
okay
so maybe yeah maybe you want to exhaust
yourself just for fun
just to see what happens
okay great
remember during your barista shift you
can always catch some cool tech
buzzwords to ask monica or your friends
about
okay great so that's something we should
remember as well
okay
so now we're just
woken up and let's get on with the day
so today let's go maybe work at the bar
let's try let's try pick up some cool
buzzwords
and let's have some coffee and see who
else we can meet at the coffee shop
we've chosen the coffee shop on purpose
to essentially try build up our network
okay so it was it was quite a thought
out higher or thought out
uh job
decision for me
so here we're over here in conversation
about apis
[Music]
and if you don't know about apis you can
actually learn quite a lot about them
just by listening to conversation
knowing that you can build your own or
knowing that you can you know use ones
that are already out there and exist
so here we go what is an api and we
better take some notes on the subject
and
he actually increased that's interesting
is it because
yeah is it from the coffee
yeah from the coffee and like the only
thing exhausting you do in the game is
probably just put your mind into study
sounds like we enjoyed our day
okay
do we have any cool turns well we know
we do
let's or should we say oh we can save
the buzzer for later that's cool i want
to see what happens if we save the
buzzword is there a list of buzzwords
okay so let's check out the list of
buzzwords
yeah always remember you can check out
the list of buzzwords in your stats to
do so here are my stats
learn about api so that is saved as a
buzzword we didn't ask and i thought
about it we saved it for another time
but i'm sure we can ask annika
now
oh cool we're going to hack a space
let's do it
[Music]
that's why local hackers love to hang
out here why don't we go around and
check out what people are working on
sounds good
okay i'm loving this see as a developer
or someone new to developing you're
going to pick up a lot of words here
like even was like prototype
uh obviously hackathon is one that we
already covered
we can ease drop on interviews i'm not
saying we ease up on everything that'd
be creepy of course but just being
surrounded by words sometimes
whiteboarding you know all these words
that you know you could be like oh and
we can ask anika later about are really
really kind of important
and of course interview secrets we need
to talk to young female over here
what do you think about this place it's
amazing
that is true it is it does seem pretty
cool
and again if you do have a hacker space
near you
it is kind of like this like you do hear
lots of interesting conversations and
you meet a lot of interesting people so
there's our achievement unlocked and as
newbies we have learned about hacker
spaces and what it's like to hang out
have them
great so we are literally increasing our
knowledge so much at the moment not just
by answering questions which is what i
like we're not just going through the
curriculum we're actually gaining a lot
of
you know other knowledge when it comes
to getting a job in tech
so which one should we do today lynn
whichever you feel like doing
okay so today let's
study some see i want to ask about apis
so maybe let's try get annika back in
some form of way
or let's let's just do some uh cs
choosing a specific category
so now i'm going
choose a specific category let's do
general computer science concepts this
time okay so this could be an
interesting one
[Music]
the process of finding and fixing bugs
in a computer program is known as
debugging
great
so we've just increased so again i think
i mean for me this is like super fun as
well i'm seeing the overall
progress we have our silency is 97 that
is so good so essentially now you could
just literally like go through all of
these without really worrying about your
science sanity too much yeah you're
taking such good care of
yourself of your mental well-being yeah
the the first way which a function calls
itself directly indirectly is known as
recursion
and third question values that an
operator operates on are known as
operands
cool so there's i think there's four
questions each time is that correct
correct
great
all right your your total cs knowledge
is now at 11 because it's a average over
all the other stats oh nice
oh that is pretty cool
so great we've answered some questions
and it's time for dinner again and
dumplings so
this is good again i feel like we are
progressing very nicely in the game but
there is still a lot to learn like
already in my mind i'm like what are
apis if i was a beginner that would be
like oh what are they and rather than um
learning more
questions we can give annika a course
and we did it so
this is what i mean about like it is
quite exciting in terms of
uh you know you'll learn a journey you
can't just go directly to the answer you
need to figure out a way to get the
answer too so let's call annika
i think annika's slowly becoming my
favorite thing
why don't you meet other characters
there are more characters and you have
meat oh amazing
so api let's talk about the api
and why is everyone going around using
acronyms that is so true there's so many
acronyms
in uh computer science and programming
so here annika tells us what an api is
the weather app i mean
everyone on their journey as a software
developer has probably made a weather
app at some point so i hope we get to
build one too or if not just learn about
what a weather app does and how it works
uh and annika here will tell us how to
do
that and we can
take it off
anything else
that's all so i guess every time we get
a buzzword saved it comes becomes an
option for us to ask annika is that
right correct
whoo
great
so there we go
and thanks mint
um
okay so now let's go back to hang out at
the hackerspace because
there's more to do in this area
so let's go around and oh what tech
trivia that is pretty fun sure let's do
it
trivia guy
so i'm guessing this is one of the games
that we've come across
let's see
how we do
let's do this here's the first question
what was your original name for java
i actually don't know this let's go with
homebrew i know that's wrong what was it
was it oh
i thought maybe because homebrew exists
it's just sort of moved over but that's
wrong
it monty python
correct i don't know how i even knew
that
oh my god c plus plus but i think it's
this one
no
i don't know
oh i don't i don't even remember coding
let's be alone
[Music]
i have no clue this trivia is really
hard
do you know then
uh-huh
yeah
the one that's related to them stone
maybe
just stone
uh-huh
next question
which has more
precision double or float the
double double
next question trivia questions are hard
but
if you
get all correct there might be some good
things happening to see
oh my god these are really hard i don't
know that either lovelace was a poet
so if you get them all correct something
fun happens is it
a legal identifier in assembly language
jesus i don't know
i'm so bad at this
[Music]
better luck next time okay so i mean
i'm guessing there's a lot of these i'm
guessing the questions won't be the same
or they might be i don't know
but
try again try to get them all correct
because there is a special thing that
shows up if you do get them right
awesome
that was a long day
great
i like the little recaps the conclusions
of the day that i share with my mum are
quite fun
do i have any cool tech terms no nothing
on my list today
but i enjoy i enjoy finding this cortex
term so that is definitely one of my
favorite activities i think
[Music]
yeah because it looks like you have
read this part of the text before you
can use the skip function oh okay cool
cool what should we do now
relax for the day maybe
and there
might be something
else you can do
let's
play some video games
let's check it out nothing beats video
games
a rhythm game okay let's go ahead and
choose
scratching the surface
use the arrow keys on the keyboard oh
jeez okay
ah i mean lucky i think i know how to
play this ah
it's like that stepping game isn't it
and that's chris's song
[Music]
oh perfect you're getting perfect hits
ah
[Music]
it's actually a lot harder than i
thought
it's designed to be hard that was
intention though
it's getting faster as well
oh my god
i don't think i get penalized for
getting it wrong though which is quite
good
is it done to the music or is it random
it's actually um down to the music
yeah i used on the python music onset
detection feature
okay there's a special like yes some
audio processing library for that
and i was able to time the beats to the
music amazing
i was thinking like is this to the music
can i somehow get more in time
whoa we certainly do high school because
that wasn't one before
is this the high score for me or just in
general with for every player
uh for you only for me only okay well
i'll try beat myself next time that is
so fun i love that i love the little
games
and if i choose another one it will be
the game again what's that music right
right yeah but uh you can see how much
uh you are missing from the perfect
score
i think we've discovered i'm not good at
tech trivia and i'm not good at playing
this game
uh this is so cool though can you show
us how you made this in code perhaps uh
yeah
let's do it
so this is actually a lot of code
i have this screen where you select the
song
and i have the screen for the actual
rhythm game
and
here's the entire
displayable that holds the rhythm game
the notes that you're seeing and
basically everything
um yeah this is actually a side project
of mine that i will be i have been
working on for a long time not just for
this game
i have the kodak github as an open
source
repo
amazing
yeah i made those uh into the engine
that anyone can plug into their vampire
game
and basically that's it there
there's just so much to code that i
wouldn't be able to dive in right now
but feel free to check this out yeah
definitely i think if we can we should
put this in the description of the video
so people can check out your repo uh
maybe have a go at you know just pulling
it down and playing around for
themselves
but yeah i love it that's that's really
impressive
um
great now i think maybe let's
instead of going back to the game now
because i don't want to go through the
whole game for everyone i want everyone
to have a go out you know playing
themselves let's maybe highlight some of
the favorite bits of the game that you
uh really enjoyed coding so which parts
of the game were the most enjoyable for
coding for you because i'd really love
to see
yeah um okay i'm gonna talk about two
parts so the first is how i come how i
um composited the character sprites and
then the other part will be how
um just when you see the like day
activity layout how does it actually
show up in code
just these two parts let's do it
all right
all right um i think a major highlight
of this game is
the graphics and how it actually works
in code
so you might recall seeing all those npc
characters the non-player characters
that have different
um colors
actually we only have one single image
for that so images character by the way
the
entire game is on archived meaning that
you will actually be able to just
download the game and check out its
content and everything is open source
amazing so i can see there's already
more characters lila marco
yeah all right yeah so if you look we
only have these four npc sprites but
in if you remember correctly in the game
they're actually tinted different colors
that's in my definitions
so we have those matrix matrix
multiplication
that you can use to create a red orange
blue and purple tint to the
npc characters amazing
and yeah
let's also demonstrate how we if
you might have noticed that the layer
and the
they are blinking
and to do that
there's something
to do that we did some image composition
so here's the base component for onika
she's actually missing the eyebrows and
the eyes and the mouth but that's just
make that that's just for
coding in her expressions
so this is a
neutral eyebrow and this is like
slightly elevated
this is the closed eye
this is the laughing eye
this is her actual eyes
mouth
smiling
and different angles and if you go here
um
i'm creating a dynamic blink component
to
anika's eyes so we're alternating
between the open eye image and the
closed eye image
so this and this
that's cool
and then anika we are always using her
base
like this if she has multiple
sets of outfits we can use different
bases as well so maybe maybe in the
future she will wear a company branded
t-shirt yeah
and then the group that we have the eyes
the eyebrows and the mouth
and we have the expressions um
i love it and how do you what's is there
a time a timing event to make her smile
and close your eyes and stuff like how
does that work
great yeah we can see here they
there are two there are three different
expressions for
onika she has a serious face
a neutral face and a laughing face
and the player has a lot more
expressions that's just because she's a
player
if we remember these keywords mutual
smile happy surprise laughs worry and
we're going back into our script
so we are showing
onika neutral and anika says i'm sorry
to hear that something something and we
show anika sirius she's talking about
something else and then we go back to
the neutral and for the player we are
doing it in line so
anika says something and the player
changes her expression to the laughing
expression
and so on and so forth
amazing
all right and this is
about this is about it for the character
sprites
and i guess another part of the game i
really want to highlight is your daily
activities
um which should be in daily
day activity choices
and you're always greeted with this line
what should we do for the day
your choices are to study cs
fundamentals
and we're gonna skip over this block
because it's just what happens when you
study
and work as a barista
here we're calling a different label
that will extend into the whole barista
story and handing out as the hackerspace
under the condition that you have
already visited the hackerspace with
onika this is a boolean
[Music]
and then taking the date off and relax
and we see those different labels
if we go to day activity relax
you can see we can take a walk in the
park which in turn calls a different
label that has something to do with the
park
play some video games
you call the video game label and then
listening to music we call the music
room screen
and then for the hacker space
there's the trivia guy
and a lot of other events like random
events that i'm not gonna spoil it for
you
and then barista
there's an entire barista story
park video game
and ooh job search that will eventually
happen
and yeah there is just so much to the
game
yeah i can see how much there is so a
lot to look forward to
yeah if we run the ramp linker it will
say has
those many dialogue blocks
these many words
and then
these many menus images and different
screens so um the three components you
see on the screen like the calendar and
the stats these are all screens we have
these many of them so do look forward to
something else happening the game down
the road amazing well i love it i think
this is so exciting i can't wait to
carry on playing on my own again i don't
want to go through the whole game
because i don't want to ruin it for
people who want to give the cigarette
themselves and hopefully complete the
game and definitely please do share your
progress with us by tweeting we'd love
to see you know how far people got in
maybe who's you know finished the game
first uh and so on so yes if you finish
the game get that tweet out so we can
know and we can celebrate that
always remember to check out the bonus
screen there's the rhythm game the music
room
the
[Music]
another links and the awesome free code
cam resources
wonderful
okay well i think that's it for now
thank you so much lynne for taking me on
the for being on the journey with me as
i explore this game and of course thank
you so much for building the game in the
first place this is incredible i'm so so
incredibly impressed i mean like words
can't even describe
alright thank you so much for playing
through and uh i hope you enjoyed it i
hope you enjoyed it as much as i enjoyed
building it yeah i know definitely it
was it was really awesome